anglo-american legal systems have been
discussed by virtually every american
president including by the way barack
obama
who not all that long ago talked about
our anglo-american legal heritage
weird it must be a racist at barack
obama again the narrative when it comes
to january 6th that it was part of a
broader american movement where's the
broader american movement
where is it where's the broader american
movement that seeks to overthrow
america's institutions
completely rewrite them destroy them
from the inside get rid of rights in the
constitution of the united states
get rid of the notion of individual
rights where is that seriously where is
the broad movement
what i see was some nuts because
statistically speaking
that's what we were watching it was like
several hundred people
but what i'm watching on the other side
is institutions that have been
completely collapsing
from the inside in favor of a mentality
that says that america's
basic notion of itself is not only wrong
and unjustified but needs to be torn
asunder
and which is why you have people like lz
granderson appearing on abc's this week
saying that america continues to be
white supremacist
in terms of marjorie green and that
particular caucus
in denouncing her many republicans
talked about how america wasn't built on
these ideas
the reality is this country was built on
white supremacy
and the reason why she supported is
because white supremacy is still very
much a part of the american fabric
so until we can acknowledge that we're
going to constantly we're going to have
facial issues particularly we're going
to have to we're going to have to end
there but you made your point
and martha raddatz uh uh everybody here
is uh is nodding along
it's very important that everybody nod
along to all of this
nonsense because if you if you don't nod
along this means that you're not woke it
means that you don't understand
america's horrific history with race
it means that you're it means that
you're just you're not part of the
movement if you don't not along
to this sort of stuff by the way what lz
granderson is referring to there
is the fact that they're some of the
more right-wing
members of the republican caucus
including fringe members like marjory
taylor green
who have posited that they wanted to
create an america first caucus
that america first caucus was supposed
to work toward an infrastructure that
reflects the architectural engineering
and aesthetic value that
befits the progeny of european
architecture
right basically people saying they don't
want brutalist architecture they want to
see
you know things that look like classical
roman architecture that is sort of
the architecture that has traditionally
characterized washington dc
also the seven page document outlining
the vision of the proposed
american america first caucus mentioned
the term anglo-saxon
they talked about anglo-saxon heritage
okay and this was treated of course
as evidence of deep abiding american
racism because
how dare you mention anglo-saxon
heritage i have a piece of awkward news
for folks
when it comes to the law and our systems
those are of anglo-saxon
extraction they just are anglo-american
legal systems have been discussed
by virtually every american president
including by the way barack obama
who not all that long ago was talking
about the importance of
habeas corpus on the floor of the senate
and talked about our anglo-american
legal heritage
weird because it must be racist at
barack obama
the world is watching what we do here
today in america
they will know what we do here today and
they'll treat all of us accordingly in
the future
our soldiers our diplomats our
journalists
anyone who travels beyond these borders
i hope we remember this as we go forward
i sincerely hope that we can protect
what's been called the great writ
a writ that's been in place in the
anglo-american
legal system for
over 700 years by the way you can see
how all of this has shifted
over the course of time for the
democrats how terms that are not racist
are now being treated as racist
if you if you believe that anglo
anglo-saxon
heritage is somehow a is somehow a rip
on people who are not of anglo-saxon
extraction
i'm jewish okay i have no dog in this
anglo-saxon heritage routine
i'm of jewish extraction so i like
antonin scalia
am not somebody who feels that that
particular
ethnic description fits me but here's
antonin scalia in italian
talking about how anglo-saxon heritage
should shape the united states
this is not a matter of historical
conjecture this is a matter of
historical fact here's
here you can call it racist as much as
you want but the simple fact is that
there are many good things about our
anglo-saxon heritage
as a culture those are good nobody is
saying that everybody in america needs
to be anglo-saxon i'd be out
right so it's scalia so probably half
the country
here's anson and scalia making exactly
this point just a few years back in 2006
the french swiss professors i had
would refer constantly to les pay
anglo-sax the anglo-saxon countries
meaning england the united states
australia new zealand
okay canada i said you know hey
my name is scalia and i'm as american as
anybody look at this face is this an
anglo-saxon face
i had never been in england but at the
end of my year
i went to england and i felt at home
there is there is no doubt that american
culture
american common culture which nobody has
to belong to
originates with english culture
okay why is that even remotely
controversial it's controversial because
anything is evidence
that the true threat to america is this
intense white supremacy that continues
to govern our lives despite the fact and
it's pretty incredible that in white
supremacist country a thoroughgoing
white supremacist country
you can expect that every five minutes
or so there's going to be a riot looting
justified by the media
and then tutted by democrats while
saying that the writers and looters have
the justification of good on their side
and of course all this ties in that
broader american narrative that is being
pushed by the left is about tearing away
at the at the civil institutions of the
society it's about tearing away
any common commonality we have between
ourselves
separate from racial tribalism
it's about making the country a worse
place on the basis of the argument that
america is already a terrible place
and it's not true america is not a
terrible place it is not a terrible
place for black people
it is not a terrible place for white
people it's not a terrible place for
green people
it is in fact the best country on earth
to live if you're a black person
name another country you would rather
live if you are if you're black
seriously i don't know i don't know
another country where i'd rather live
as a jew it's an amazing amazing country
why the the intense push by the left
to rewrite the american bargain on the
back of lies about what america is
and then to wink and nod at people who
are engaging
in acts of vandalism looting rioting
burning
arson attacks on police officers
and to treat that as not some form of
larger insurrectionist attempt to
overthrow these institutions in the soft
non-legal sense
i don't know what you're watching i
don't know you're watching you have a
right as an american
to expect that the systems of power in
the united states the systems of
government under the constitution that
are constrained by the constitution of
the declaration
are not overthrown by by people who wish
to see them die
but uh i'll say that that right is
certainly being infringed
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe